the tens nightclub has become a hub a
hyena spice Supply operations posing a
significant threat to the city meet up
with agent Lee and eliminate this
growing problem
s
[Music]
agents receive a mission briefing
stating that they are to meet up with
fellow division agent Lee
their goal is to disrupt the hyenas by
supply lines
the agents have had a long week so they
equipped their super lazy skill build so
they don't have to focus on aiming too
much
they arrive at the designated location a
nightclub known to be a front line for
the hyenas illicit activities their
first task is to infiltrate the
nightclub without alerting the enemy
with careful coordination they breach
the establishment and secure the
workshop with the hyenas process this
spice however they progress has soon
impeded when the hyenas launched a
surprise ambush
the agents fight back overcoming the
hyenas and push forward to reach the VIP
lounge with a hope together more Intel
as they make their way through the dimly
lit corridors they face a sit back as
the lights suddenly go out plunging them
into darkness undeterred they reactivate
the lights however Lee against Manny's
advice has pushed forward on her own and
would be taken down by the hyenas
Agent Lee status deceased
God damn it
told her to wait
the agents once again move on and would
catch up with the chemist who was
responsible for manufacturing the spice
the area becomes a Battleground as the
agents engage in a firefight to secure
the location
amidst the chaos they disable the water
supply disrupting the chemist's
operations
with the chemist being cornered the
agents eliminate their target and move
on to take agent Lee's body honoring
their fallen comrade
prior to the outbreak Lee worked as a
paramedic in Washington DC
her regular duties often led her to a
prominent nightclub situated in downtown
DC
unbeknownst to her the establishment's
owner was involved in distributing drugs
to its patrons
despite Lee's diligent efforts to report
the illicit activities of the nightclub
to the police no substantial evidence
could be obtained to incriminate the
club owner
coincidentally the owner continued to
engage in drug trafficking while Lee
found herself repeatedly attending to
drug overdose cases within the club one
encounter driven by frustration Lee
approached the club owner leading to a
confrontation that caught the attention
of City agencies placing her in a
difficult situation
took you long enough I don't work for
you how many people OD on your ship this
time hey I'm not responsible for what
people bring into my club that's
and you know it oh temporarily
you remember what happened last time
you my boy is recording this entire
conversation
you want to keep making threats you keep
making spice I'll keep making threats
you're adorable like a little angry
puppy
good thing the city put Alicia on you
you might bite someone
after the outbreak Lee continued to work
as a paramedic which took her to the
nightclub again this time one female
customer had overdosed and Asia was
treating the patient her Smartwatch was
activated
[Music]
you're pretty
I need you to sit down for me
how much did you have
just like died last night
okay
I'm gonna need you to drink this water
for me okay
can you do that
sure
I know I'm so pretty
no I mean your watch silly
it's all orange now
it's pretty
finally
a few months later the club owner joined
the hyenas and named herself the chemist
it's completely safe
just a little more potent than the last
batch
this is crazy I can't feel my face
you feel Invincible right totally
like you could get shot in the stomach
five times and still run a marathon yeah
where did you treat this with don't
worry about it it's safe enough I really
want to fight someone right now good
then it's working
the chemists use the nightclub is a drug
lab for producing spice a drug developed
by the hyenas that enhance strength for
a short period of time
Lee went back once again to the
nightclub but this time as a division
agent division coordinator Manny Ortega
dispatched agents to support her
Lee was told to wait for backup but
unfortunately she chose not to and was
killed while fighting members of the
chemist crew
a team was sent out to recover Lee's
body for a proper burial
wash yes it's not that complicated but
but what's with the
with the lights grow better when exposed
to different kinds of light
and different colored lights have
different wavelengths which can impede
or encourage different properties in the
plants okay cool
so the EDM the vibrations help the
plants grow bigger stronger faster cool
but like how it effectively simulates
wind which causes the plants to fight
against the vibrations
a little stress is good too much stress
and the stock of the plant can break are
you a drug dealer or a chemist yes
not too much to talk about with this one
as I had a fairly straightforward story
with a solid conclusion at the end
awesome level design though but there
was one calm that I didn't play earlier
that got me thinking
good to see you're still alive thanks
when you didn't come in I was worried
someone took you out nope kind of busy
here we talk about this later you're
orange perceptive you go off Mission
you're supposed to be red guess that
means I'm not off mission
you're gonna help me with the spice OD
or keep quizzing me on protocol
nothing hugely new heard here in this
interaction but it really set the scene
for how sensitive Isaac is when it comes
to flagging agents as Rogue
obviously Lee wasn't flagged as Rogue in
this situation but for them to be
concerned about it makes me suddenly
realize how restricted the agents really
were at the beginning there
I've always had the Illusion in the back
of my head that agents are free to go
and do anything they want provided it's
in line with their primary mission to
save what remains but it sounds like
Isaac is far more restrictive than that
it makes me wonder how many agents went
rogue while doing good things that would
eventually get mowed down by division
agents or would ditch their division
gear altogether
was just a thought
anyway thank you once again for watching
these videos and extremist malice
extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]